This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听听如何学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《the hard way》。在2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners,
一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝，在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，
wherever you are in the world. Whatever day it is, I hope you're having a great day. Welcome back for another episode. So you've read the title. I don't think it's any surprise that today I'm going to talk about my experience with depression in my 20s. I have depression. I've had it for many years.
无论你身处世界的哪个角落。无论今天是什么日子，我都希望你过得愉快。欢迎收听另一期节目。所以你已经读了标题。我想今天我要谈谈我在20多岁时经历抑郁症的经历，这应该不会让人感到意外。我有抑郁症。我得这个病已经很多年了。
And I really think it's time that we talk about it. It's taken me quite a while to really, I would say, process what I wanted to say in this episode. I think out of fear that maybe, you know, my words could be misconstrued. My experience could be misconstrued. But also because of, you know, a level of shame, you know, it's really, it's a lot to really engage with that there are millions of people listening to what can be very deeply intimate and vulnerable parts of my life. and sometimes there are things that I don't really feel prepared to share because I think that what you make public is kind of what you allow people to comment on and what you allow people to have an opinion on.
我真的觉得是时候谈谈这件事了。我花了不少时间才真正开始处理我想在这集节目中说的话。我想这是出于恐惧，也许，你知道，我的话可能会被曲解。我的经历可能会被曲解。但也是因为，你知道，某种程度的羞耻感，你知道，要真正面对有数百万人在收听我生活中可能非常私密和脆弱的部分，这真的需要付出很多，有时有些事情我真的觉得自己还没有准备好分享，因为我认为你公开的东西就是你允许别人评论的东西，也是你允许别人持有意见的东西。
But I also don't think it's a secret. You know, I did an episode a while back titled, Why Am I So Unhappy? I feel like that's a big clue. And I've also talked about, you know, my experience with antidepressants back in the earlier days of the show. But for a mental health podcast, it felt like, it was time to do somewhat of a comprehensive episode on this. So today let's talk about it. Let's talk about depression in our 20s. This episode is going to be, I think, equal parts more
但我也认为这不是什么秘密。你知道，我前段时间做过一期节目，标题是《为什么我这么不开心？》我觉得这是一个巨大的线索。而且我在节目早期的时候也谈到过，你知道，我使用抗抑郁药的经历。但是对于一个心理健康播客来说，我觉得是时候做一期关于这个主题的综合性节目了。所以今天我们来谈谈它。我们来谈谈20多岁时的抑郁症。这一集将会，我认为，在很大程度上更加
scientific and more personal than most of my episodes, because I think when we're approaching things like mental health, you can't be coming at it with your own theories. And there's also no absence of really incredible research into improving the lives of people who have this condition. It's also a sad reality that stigma is very much alive and well. I think as society, we are getting a lot better at accepting certain truths about depression, but a big part of why stigma persists is because of a lack of accurate knowledge. So kind of consider this your introductory guide, your immersion into the psychology, but also the personal experiences of someone who is going for this. We're going to discuss why depression is more than just a blanket term and how it looks
科学，也比我的大多数节目更具个人色彩，因为我认为当我们处理心理健康之类的事情时，你不能带着你自己的理论来对待它。而且，关于改善患有这种疾病的人的生活，从来不乏真正了不起的研究。另一个悲伤的现实是，污名化依然存在且非常严重。我认为作为一个社会，我们在接受关于抑郁症的某些真相方面正在变得越来越好，但污名化之所以持续存在，很大一部分原因是因为缺乏准确的知识。所以不妨把这当作你的入门指南，让你沉浸在心理学中，同时也了解一个正在经历这一切的人的个人经历。我们将讨论为什么抑郁症不仅仅是一个泛泛的术语，以及它看起来是如何
different for everyone, including people who may be very high functioning and visibly seem very well and very okay. It's a huge misconception that you need to look and behave a certain way to be depressed. That's a myth that we are definitely aiming to bust today. We're also going to examine the different types of depression, the origins of depression, including some of the early historical recognition of this condition and some of the secrets and surprises that our biology and our DNA holds, as well as the role of things like adrenaline, like family environment and even positive experiences like graduating. You know, our minds are very, very cryptic, a bit of a black box at times. And I think depression is a lot more than being sad or based on what we perceive
因人而异，包括那些可能功能极高、表面上看非常健康、非常正常的人。认为你需要表现出某种特定的外表和行为才是抑郁症，这是一个巨大的误区。这绝对是我们今天要打破的一个神话。我们还将探讨抑郁症的不同类型、抑郁症的起源，包括对这种状况的早期历史认知，以及我们的生物学和DNA所蕴含的一些秘密和惊奇，还有肾上腺素、家庭环境甚至像毕业这样的积极经历所起的作用。你知道，我们的心灵非常非常神秘，有时就像一个黑匣子。我认为抑郁症远不止是悲伤，也不是基于我们所感知到的
as negative events in our lives. There's also been some really fascinating research coming out in this space that I think deserves a very special place in this episode, particularly around the use of things like psychedelics and certain illicit substances to treat depression. We're going to tread lightly because the research is still ongoing, but I think we're at this kind of new frontier of how we approach a lot of different mental health disorders, including depression. So although we're going to talk about typical treatments, I really want to speak about my own experience on antidepressants, kind of some of the myths behind why exercise is not the secret cure we all imagine it to be. We're also going to leave some room for new findings.
我们生活中的负面事件。这个领域也出现了一些非常迷人的研究，我认为它在这集节目中应该占据一个非常特殊的地位，特别是关于使用迷幻药和某些违禁物质来治疗抑郁症的研究。我们会谨慎对待，因为研究仍在进行中，但我认为我们正处于对待许多不同心理健康失调（包括抑郁症）方式的新前沿。因此，虽然我们要谈论典型的治疗方法，但我真的很想谈谈我使用抗抑郁药的亲身经历，以及为什么运动并非我们想象中那种神奇解药的一些神话。我们也会为新的发现留出一些空间
and knowledge and hopefully come out of this knowing, I would say more than about 95% of the population does know about depression. There's so much information that I want to cover. Maybe we can do a part two, but if you're looking for an overview and also some of the more fascinating elements that we don't see discussed very often, hopefully this is the space where you can learn. I want to quickly put out a brief disclaimer.
和知识，希望大家听完后能了解到，可以说比95%的人对抑郁症的了解还要多。有太多的信息我想涵盖。也许我们可以做一个第二部分，但如果你正在寻找一个概述，以及一些我们不常看到的更吸引人的元素，希望这里就是你能学习到知识的地方。我想快速发布一个简短的免责声明。
this episode is for entertainment purposes only, maybe not entertainment episodes, informational purposes, but please do not use this episode for diagnostic or therapeutic advice. If you find yourself relating to this discussion, or this does make you distressed, please, please reach out to someone for professional support. I unfortunately do not know each and every one of you and I don't know your story or your needs. and as we'll come to see, we all have different experiences, but there will be links in the description for further information. And if you're someone who's maybe listening to this to better understand the experiences of a partner or a friend, a sibling parent, really anyone,
本集节目仅供娱乐目的，也许不是娱乐节目，而是信息目的，但请不要将本集节目用于诊断或治疗建议。如果你发现自己与本讨论产生共鸣，或者这让你感到痛苦，请务必向专业支持寻求帮助。很遗憾，我并不认识你们每一个人，也不知道你们的故事或需求，正如我们将要看到的，我们都有不同的经历，但在描述中会有链接供获取更多信息。如果你可能是为了更好地理解伴侣、朋友、兄弟姐妹、父母，或者真的任何人的经历而收听节目的人，
firstly, thank you for joining us. I think it's really beautiful that you're here to learn. And there will also be resources on how to support people with depression as well. So like I said before, there's a lot to cover in this episode. I'm going to stop rambling. And we're going to dive into all the science and the psychology and a bit of my personal experience as well. So let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
首先，感谢你加入我们。我认为你能来学习是一件非常美妙的事情。这里还将提供关于如何支持抑郁症患者的资源。所以正如我之前所说，这一集有太多内容要讲了。我要停止唠叨了。我们要深入探讨所有的科学、心理学以及我的一些个人经历。让我们开始吧。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strength. modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们的强力现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更有
fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-HartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWO%。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我很乐意在某天谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克，有时当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢与输的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上活着的时候做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的
inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马林西尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All righty. So I don't think I can do an episode like this without explaining why I think it's so important. we have more discussions around depression and mental health in general, particularly in our 20s. And as a part of that, I want to talk really frankly and openly with you about my own experience.
劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好了。所以我觉得，如果不解释为什么我认为围绕抑郁症和整体心理健康进行更多讨论如此重要，尤其是对于我们20多岁的人来说，我可能无法制作这样一期节目。作为其中的一部分，我想非常坦率、公开地和你们谈谈我自己的经历。
So I've had, I guess, clinical depression for like five years. It comes and goes. And I think sometimes I feel like I've spent more years of my 20s kind of dealing with it than I have really enjoying this time. that, you know, the best years of my life have somehow been claimed by this state of mind and by this condition. You know, last year in particular was really hard. It was the best year of my life. Everything I'd ever wanted kind of came true. Everything was going right. It was these constant milestones and celebrations. And I think despite all of that, all of that perceived external success, I felt really deeply, deeply unhappy. I would look at my life. I would look at my life. and I knew I should be excited. I knew I should feel up on cloud nine and I just couldn't be there.
所以我想我大概有五年的临床抑郁症史。它时好时坏。有时候我觉得，我20多岁的好几年时间似乎都在和它对抗，而没有真正去享受这段时光。你知道的，我人生中最美好的岁月，不知为何就被这种心态和这种状况给占据了。特别是去年，真的非常艰难。那本该是我人生中最棒的一年。我一直以来梦寐以求的一切都实现了。一切都很顺利。到处都是不断的里程碑和庆祝活动。然而我认为，尽管有这一切，所有那些被外界看到的成功，我内心深处却感到非常非常不快乐。我看着自己的生活。我看着自己的生活，明明知道自己应该感到兴奋。我明知自己应该欣喜若狂，但就是做不到。
And it was so frustrating to me to not have, you know, I guess access to that joy or to the things about myself that I valued, like my creativity and just my kind of zest for life. And I know that that experience, having talked to listeners of the show, having talked to friends, is not a unique one. It's not one that I'm alone in experiencing. That's why talking about this is so important to me on a really vulnerable note, because I know it's hard to talk about. I know that this side of me might not be what people want to see or hear about. I know that our knee-jerk reaction is to feel shame or embarrassment towards open discussions
无法体验到那种快乐，或者无法拥有我曾经珍视的自我特质，比如我的创造力和对生活的无限热情，这让我感到非常沮丧。而且我知道，在与节目的听众交流过、与朋友交谈过后，这种经历并非我独有。我并不是唯一一个有这种感受的人。这就是为什么在这里以非常坦诚的态度谈论这件事对我来说如此重要，因为我知道这很难开口。我知道我这一面可能并不是人们想要看到或听到的。我也知道我们的本能反应是对公开讨论产生羞耻感或尴尬感
around mental health. But I'm hoping that seeing how this has played out for me and continues to impact me, using some of my own experiences, but also the academic and the side of the health. psychological and the scientific knowledge can really minimize that shame for yourself. And also, as an example that this can be your experience and you can still have a really fulfilling and fantastic life. There's good days, there's bad days.
围绕心理健康的讨论。但我希望，通过了解这件事在我身上是如何发展并继续影响我的，结合我自身的一些经历，以及学术、健康、心理学和科学的知识，能够真正将你们心中的那份羞耻感降到最低。同时，这也是一个例子：即使你经历过这些，你依然可以拥有一个非常充实且精彩的人生。生活有美好的一天，也有糟糕的一天。
I guess that's part of the game I'm still kind of adjusting to. There's no doubt that we are seeing rising rates of not just depression, but general unhappiness and alienation in this generation. we know that young people have a higher rate of diagnosis for these conditions. There's even some estimates that put it at like 30 to 35 percent, way more than what we saw in previous decades, but also in older age groups. And it's during the ages of around 16 to 29, early 30s,
我想这是我仍在适应的生活一部分。毫无疑问，我们看到这一代人不仅抑郁症发病率在上升，普遍的不快乐和疏离感也在增加。我们知道年轻人患这些疾病的确诊率更高。甚至有一些估计显示这一比例达到了30%到35%，远远超过了我们在前几个以及更年长年龄段中所看到的水平。而且正是在16岁到29岁、30岁出头这段时期，
that typically our first major depressive episode, if you go on to develop a major depressive disorder, normally occurs. So we really want to start talking about it earlier. The factors I think that we can point to for this upward trend are really endless. You know, on a positive note, reduced stigma in society is leading people to receive a diagnosis. And, you know, previous generations may not have received that despite experiencing all the same symptoms. And also, generationally, I do think there is this kind of increasing malaise with the state of the world, reduced protective factors like a sense of community,
通常情况下，如果我们发展为重度抑郁障碍，我们的第一次重大抑郁发作就会在这个时期出现。所以我们真的很想更早地开始讨论这个话题。我认为导致这种上升趋势的因素可以说是无休止的。从积极的方面来看，社会污名化的减少正在引导人们去寻求诊断。而且，你知道的，尽管经历了所有相同的症状，前几代人可能并没有得到诊断。同时，从代际角度来看，我确实认为对于世界现状有一种不断增加的沮丧感，保护性因素在减少，比如社区归属感，
which we know has really disappeared for a lot of people in this generation, significant pressures to perform and be exceptional, financial uncertainty, COVID, a sense of just like general doom about the future. And those are only really, I think, a handful of explanations that psychologists and researchers are pointing to for a lot more, people coming to them saying, I'm having this experience, I think I might be depressed. We're never going to eliminate conditions like depression, but I think the existence of depression in society is not the concern, it's the rate at which so many of us are struggling without the necessary societal and
我们知道这一代人的这种感觉对很多人来说已经真正消失了，表现和变得优秀的巨大压力、财务不确定性、新冠疫情，以及对未来普遍的末日感。我认为，这些只是心理学家和研究人员指出的一小部分解释，用来回答为什么会有更多人找到他们并说：“我正在经历这种状况，我觉得我可能抑郁了。”我们永远无法彻底消除像抑郁症这样的疾病，但我想，社会上存在抑郁症并不是最令人担忧的，令人担忧的是我们当中有这么多人正在苦苦挣扎，却缺乏必要的社会和
community and medical supports. You know, this condition has always had a place within the human experience. This is not some new illness. It's not some fad condition. It's not some fad condition. it's very, very real and very, very consequential. If we look back at history, although terms like clinical depression or major depressive disorder and now how we would label this experience back in even like ancient Greece, ancient Rome, they had a name for this. They had a different name for what we're talking about and it was melancholia, meaning a feeling of deep, profound sadness, a sadness that kind of sits in your bones.
社区以及医疗支持。你知道，这种状况在人类历史中一直有一席之地。这不是什么新鲜的疾病。它不是什么一时的潮流疾病。它不是什么一时的潮流疾病，它是非常非常真实且影响深远的。如果我们回顾历史，尽管像临床抑郁症或重度抑郁障碍这样的术语是我们现在用来标记这种经历的词汇，甚至在古希腊和古罗马时期，他们就为这种经历起过名字。对于我们现在谈论的事情，他们有不同的称呼，那就是“忧郁症”（melancholia），意思是感受到一种深深的、刻骨铭心的悲伤，一种仿佛深入骨髓的悲伤。
and there are so many historical documents and parts of history, paintings, sculptures, folklore, even Bible verses that show us that not only did this condition we now know as depression exist, but there are also efforts to treat it. It was viewed as a medical condition. And yet we still have such a hard time acknowledging it in our society, despite it being what some are calling a literal epidemic and very historically significant. You know, you'd think that we'd have. have used those thousands of years to actually get better at integrating this condition into our
并且有这么多的历史文件和历史片段、绘画、雕塑、民间传说，甚至圣经经文向我们展示，我们现在所知道的被称为抑郁症的这种状况不仅存在，而且当时也有治疗它的努力。它当时被视为一种医疗状况。然而，尽管有些人称之为真正意义上的流行病且具有重大的历史意义，我们在社会中承认它仍然是如此困难。你知道的，你本会以为我们已经利用这数千年的时间，真正提高了将这种状况融入我们
understanding and our compassion for others. But still, I think we endure it in silence. When we do have the courage to ask for help, maybe you don't receive the support that you need. Or at times, we're kind of convinced that we're totally fine. It's all in our head just to get over it, to grin and bear it. And that fallacy, that avoidance and suppression can somehow magically cure you is so false. It's, you know, it's without a doubt not true. Depression is so much more than just sadness. It's a medical condition, perhaps one of the most common that we see, and it's not shameful. That shame is societal, that shame is learned, and it can be unlearned. I know this metaphor has been used to death, but your brain is an organ, is a part of your body like any other.
对他人理解和同情的能力。然而我认为，我们仍然在默默忍受它。当我们终于有勇气寻求帮助时，也许并没有得到所需的支持。或者有时，我们被灌输这样一种观念：我们完全没事，这只是我们想太多，只要挺过去就行，咬咬牙忍一忍就过去了。这种谬论，即通过逃避和压抑就能神奇地治愈你，是极其错误的。毫无疑问，这是不真实的。抑郁症远不止是悲伤那么简单。它是一种医疗状况，也许是我们看到的最常见的疾病之一，而且这并不丢脸。这种羞耻感是社会造成的，是后天习得的，而它也是可以被消除的。我知道这个隐喻已经被用滥了，但你的大脑就像身体的其他部位一样，是一个器官、是你身体的一部分。
And sometimes it's going to have a few problems, the same way that our bones break, the same way that we get scrapes and bruises and our arteries clug and our heart speed a little bit too fast, sometimes our brains find themselves in a state of chemical imbalance, or they get bumped and you know symbolically, metaphorically bruised by the things we experience. I think what I found in my own experience was that from the outside, I looked really, really fine. I think I didn't feel fine, but I was still going to work. I was still interacting with my friends. I was still getting good grades at university. All the feelings and symptoms that I was experiencing were very solitary. And because of what I thought depression looked like, I didn't really feel like I
有时它会出现一些问题，就像我们的骨头会骨折，就像我们会擦伤和碰伤，我们的动脉会堵塞，我们的心跳会过快一样，有时我们的大脑也会陷入化学物质失衡的状态，或者在象征性、隐喻性上被我们的经历所撞击和擦伤。我想我在自己的经历中发现的是，从外表上看，我真的非常非常好。我觉得自己感觉不好，但我依然在去上班。我依然在与朋友交往。我在大学里依然能拿到好成绩。我所经历的所有感受和症状都是非常孤立的。由于我对抑郁症固有印象的限制，我真的不觉得自己
deserved to feel this way or to accept the diagnosis that I had. To me, the depression I saw was really dramatized in the movies, in books and TV shows. The cases I saw that were acknowledged by society and those around me were very visible. It was someone laying in bed for hours, which, you know, I did do, but it was also someone who missed work or school whose kind of hair was always a mess, who walked around like a zombie. I saw depression as tearful, as very outward and as causing dysfunction. And for many of us, that is the experience, and it's one that's extremely difficult. but from the outside, in my case, I was still functioning. I wasn't crying, if anything, I couldn't cry because I really couldn't feel anything,
配得上这种感受，或者去接受我被诊断出的事实。在我看来，我所看到的抑郁症在电影、书籍和电视节目中被极大地戏剧化了。社会和周围人所认可的病例是非常显而易见的。那是一个人躺在床上好几个小时，你知道的，我也确实这么做过；但那也是指那些旷工或旷课、头发总是乱糟糟、像僵尸一样走来走去的人。我眼中的抑郁症是伴随着泪水、非常外露且会导致功能失调的。对我们许多人来说，这确实是我们的经历，而且这极其痛苦，但在我这种情况下，从外表上看，我仍在正常运转。我没有哭，如果要说的话，我甚至哭不出来，因为我真的什么感觉都没有，
but I still did all the things that people expect you to do, and that didn't really match my perception of what I thought depression would look like. I think our difficulty accepting the reality of this goes deeper than just the stigma that we've spoken about, and it's this larger idea of a misrepresentation that our society, likes to, you know, make things look dramatic, likes to make things look a lot more in, you know, not intense than they are, but likes to make it a little bit of a spectacle out of the things that we go through. And like I said before, we see that in so many types of media that we're consuming, this idea that your life needs to be absolutely falling apart for you to be depressed.
但我依然做完了人们期望你做的所有事情，这与我心目中抑郁症应有的样子实在不相符。我认为我们难以接受现实，其根源不仅仅在于我们之前谈论过的污名化，还在于更广泛的虚假呈现——我们的社会喜欢把事情搞得很有戏剧性，喜欢把事情表现得比实际情况更加夸张，喜欢把我们经历的苦难变成一场场奇观。正如我刚才所说，在我们消费的许多类型的媒体中都能看到这一点：这种观点认为，你的人生必须彻底崩溃，你才算患上了抑郁症。
And that's something that needs to be corrected. There, there needs to be, some kind of understanding that you can still be depressed and everything in your life can be going really, really well. So that's the first misconception I really want to talk about. Depression is not just one condition. It's not a blanket diagnosis. And it is going to look very different from person to person. To understand this, we kind of need to look closer at the DSM. And this is what we called the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of Mental Disorders. Essentially, it's like the Bible of pretty much every mental disorder you would experience and it lists exactly how to diagnose a condition and what it's going to look like. Depression was one of the founding conditions,
而这一点是需要被纠正的。我们需要有一种理解，那就是：你依然可以患有抑郁症，而你生活中的一切都可以进展得非常非常顺利。所以这是我想谈论的第一个误区。抑郁症不仅仅是一种单一的疾病。它不是一概而论的诊断。而且因人而异，每个人的表现会非常不同。为了理解这一点，我们需要更仔细地查看《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）。基本上，它就像是你可能经历的几乎每一种精神障碍的圣经，它精确列出了如何诊断一种疾病以及它的表现形式。抑郁症是最初的病症之一，
but previously, anyone who met the symptom cut off for depression would be diagnosed with major depressive disorder. That is what I think our society, the typical image, of what this condition is. But on a clinical level, it requires two or more depressive episodes, which is a discrete period of time, often a minimum of two weeks, when we experience at least five of the following things. We have a depressed mood for most of the day, a diminished interest or kind of pleasure in the activities that we used to enjoy,
但在过去，任何达到抑郁症状标准的人都会被诊断为重度抑郁障碍。这就是我认为我们社会普遍认为的这种疾病的典型形象。但在临床层面上，它要求有两次或更多的抑郁发作，这是一个明确的时间段，通常最短为两周，在此期间我们体验到以下至少五种症状：我们大部分时间都情绪低落，对曾经喜欢活动的兴趣或乐趣明显减退，
significant weight gain or loss, insomnia or sleeping too much, agitation, fatigue or loss of energy, feelings of worthlessness or excessive guilt, a diminished ability to think or concentrate. And finally, these recurrent thoughts of death. Like many mental health conditions, it has little to do with what's actually happening around you. You can have a loving family. You can have friends. You can have a dream job. You can have the kind of life that you've always wanted. and you can still have depression. But for others, this typical definition of a major depressive disorder isn't going to be their experience, right? And that's something that psychologists have really identified in recent decades.
体重明显增加或减少，失眠或嗜睡，烦躁不安，疲劳或精力丧失，感到毫无价值或过度的内疚，思考或集中注意力的能力下降。最后，这些反复出现的死亡想法。就像许多心理健康状况一样，它与你周围实际发生的事情关系不大。你可以拥有一个充满爱的家庭。你可以拥有朋友。你可以拥有一份梦想中的工作。你可以拥有你一直想要的生活，但你仍然会患上抑郁症。但对于其他人来说，这种对重度抑郁障碍的典型定义并不是他们的亲身经历，对吧？这也是心理学家在近几十年中真正识别出的情况。
They had clients coming in saying, you know, I don't have these lows that are intense as those associated with a major depressive disorder. But I can't shake this sadness. And it's been years. Some days, you know, are better than others, but there's this overtone of really deep unhappiness and hopelessness in my life. This is what we now call persistent depressive disorder. It's also known by other names like high functioning depression or dyshthymia. This is what I now know I think I had, and well, I still have it to this day. And the criteria are a lot less strict, but it really points to the longevity of this type of depression. You need to have a depressed mood for more days than not.
他们的客户来到诊所时说：“你知道吗，我没有那些与重度抑郁障碍相关的强烈低谷。但我无法摆脱这种悲伤。而且已经持续好几年了。有些日子，你知道的，会比其他日子好一些，但我的生活中总是笼罩着一层深深的不快乐和绝望。”这就是我们现在所称的持续性抑郁障碍（persistent depressive disorder）。它也有其他名字，比如高功能抑郁症（high functioning depression）或恶劣心境（dysthymia）。这就是我现在知道的我曾经得过的病，而且老实说，直到今天我仍然患有它。它的标准要宽松得多，但它确实指出了这种抑郁症的持久性。你需要在大多数日子里都处于情绪低落的状态，
And here's kind of the kicker for at least two years. But you only need to have two of the below criteria, not five. So the same kind of list that we talked about before, a low mood, sense of hopelessness, a lack of energy, low self-esteem. And this condition is much more nuanced, like we said, than just sadness. The same way that each person is a really unique combination of so many factors and experiences and stories, their minds and their brains are also going to be this unique combination. So I think it's really important that we recognize that distinction and adapt to the diversity by which these symptoms can appear. We also see conditions under this umbrella like seasonal affective disorder or seasonal depression,
这里最关键的一点是：持续至少两年。但你只需要符合以下两项标准即可，而不需要五项。所以就是我们之前谈到的那个清单：情绪低落、绝望感、缺乏精力、自卑。正如我们所说，这种疾病比单纯的悲伤要微妙得多。就像每个人都是无数因素、经历和故事的独特组合一样，他们的心灵和大脑也将是这种独特的组合。所以我认为，认识到这种区别并适应这些症状表现出的多样性是非常重要的。在这个大伞下，我们还能看到其他疾病，比如季节性情感障碍或季节性抑郁，
postnatal depression, depression associated with bipolar disorder. And then finally, adjustment disorder with depressed mood. That's also known as situational depression. This looks like major depression in many ways, but instead of being brought on by what we might see as certain biological mechanisms or neurological roots, it's brought on by a specific event or situation that's been really, really hard, like the death of a loved one or serious illness, a divorce,
产后抑郁，与双相情感障碍相关的抑郁。最后是伴有抑郁情绪的适应障碍。这也称为情境性抑郁（situational depression）。它在许多方面看起来像重度抑郁，但它不是由我们可能看到的某些生物学机制或神经学根源引起的，而是由某个特定的、真的非常艰难的事件或情境引起的，比如挚爱之人的离世、重病、离婚、
facing financial difficulties, even a breakup, all of which are these events that are discreet, they essentially overwhelm our capacity to cope, you know, as it's only natural and kind of expected in those situations. Situational depression, the symptoms tend to start within three months of the initial experience and it follows a very similar pattern to major depression with the caveat being that often it's quite comorbid with other conditions like anxiety or things like substance use, you know, including alcohol. I think what always complicates our perception of this condition isn't just the
面对经济困难，甚至是分手，所有这些都是独立的事件，它们从根本上压垮了我们的应对能力，你知道的，在那种情况下这其实是很自然且意料之中的。情境性抑郁的症状往往在初次经历后的三个月内开始出现，它遵循与重度抑郁非常相似的模式，不同之处在于它常常与其他疾病高度共病，比如焦虑症或物质滥用（包括酒精）等问题。我认为，总是使我们对这种疾病的看法变得复杂的事情，不仅是
variety of the ways that it can manifest, but also the fact that depression or feeling depressed is both a clinical term and one that we can use to describe a certain feeling. You know, it's both a symptom and a condition, but one of those things is temporary. And a question I get asked a lot is, is this kind of my life now? Will I ever be cured? When's this, when's this going to end? I think when we are in this state, we often need the security of a timeline
它表现出来的多样性，还有这样一个事实：抑郁或感到抑郁既是一个临床术语，也是我们可以用来描述某种特定感受的词汇。你知道的，它既是一个症状，也是一种疾病，但这两者中有一种是暂时的。我经常被问到的一个问题是：这就是我今后的生活吗？我能被治愈吗？这什么时候、什么时候才会结束？我认为当我们处于这种状态时，我们常常需要一个时间表的安全感
to give us the light at the end of the tunnel. How can we kind of go on with life if we think that this will never end? And that's what depression convinces you, that it won't, that it's all pointless. And if you just get one thing from this episode, one tiny, tiny piece of advice or wisdom, it's that it's not pointless.
来给我们提供隧道尽头的微光。如果我们认为这一切永远不会结束，我们怎么能继续生活下去？而这正是抑郁症让你相信的事情，它让你觉得这一切都不会结束，这一切都毫无意义。如果你能从这一集中获得任何东西，哪怕是一点点微不足道的建议或智慧，那就是：这一切并非毫无意义。
Trust me, I know so intimately how it feels to look at life, this thing that we think should be precious and feel nothing, for nothing to make us happy, to be stripped of joy. But I also know what it feels like to kind of slowly see that perspective change. It's like the first flowers after spring, you know, your brain is slowly defrosting all those happy hormones that it's kept from you. And I really do understand the desire for a quick fix as well. You know, sadly our brain is quite cryptic and the length of this condition is really going to depend on a lot of factors.
相信我，我非常清楚那种审视生活的感觉，这种我们认为应该无比珍贵的东西却让我们毫无感觉，没有任何事情能让我们快乐，快乐被剥夺殆尽。但我也知道那种慢慢看到这种观点发生改变的感觉。就像春天过后的第一朵花一样，你知道的，你的大脑正在慢慢解冻那些它一直为你保留的快乐荷尔蒙。我也确实理解人们对快速解决方法的渴望。遗憾的是，我们的大脑相当神秘，这种状况持续的时间很大程度上取决于许多因素。
The primary one being the origins and the root cause. And what about our environment or our context or our protective factors can be altered? So let me set the stage and kind of dive into the science behind why we feel this way sometimes, where it's coming from. you know, depression is not a personal flaw. It's not a personal weakness. It is this hidden system and interplay of genetic and biological and environmental interactions. If depression, you know, was truly a choice or a personal weakness, you know, we could hypothetically be able to overcome it with sheer willpower and positive thinking. And while some people would have you believe that, that that is possible, those are not the kinds of people that we want to be
首要因素是它的起源和根本原因。以及我们的环境、背景或保护因素中，有哪些是可以改变的？所以，让我来做个铺垫，深入探讨一下我们有时会有这种感觉、这些情绪从何而来的科学原理。你知道的，抑郁症不是个人的缺陷。它不是个人软弱的表现。它是遗传、生物和环境相互作用的一个隐藏系统和交织过程。如果抑郁症真的只是一种选择或个人弱点，那么我们理论上应该能够通过纯粹的意志力和积极思维来克服它。虽然有些人会让你相信这是可能的，但那些并不是我们想要去
listening to, especially when it comes to our mental health. We're going to approach this from the model of the four P's. So what that means is predisposing factors, precipitating, perpetuating, and protective. There's kind of not just one secret formula to what makes a depressed person, I guess, versus someone who is not depressed. But we can use this model to kind of break down our innate and personal vulnerabilities. And then also what we can use to mitigate. our symptoms if we are someone who has this condition. So predisposing factors are kind of areas of vulnerability that increase your risk. When we talk about depression, the first one that often comes to mind is genetics. If you're, you know, looking for something else to blame your parents for,
倾听的人，尤其是在涉及我们心理健康的时候。我们将从“四个P”模型来探讨这个问题。这意味着：诱发因素（predisposing factors）、促发因素（precipitating）、维持因素（perpetuating）以及保护因素（protective）。对于是什么造就了一个抑郁的人，而不是一个不抑郁的人，并没有什么单一的秘密公式。但我们可以用这个模型来剖析我们天生和个人的脆弱性。然后，如果我们是不幸患有这种疾病的人，我们也可以利用这些来减轻我们的症状。因此，诱发因素是那些会增加你患病风险的脆弱领域。当我们谈论抑郁症时，首先浮现脑海的往往是遗传。如果你正在寻找
this one might be for you, but our genetics are inherited from our mother and our father. And they essentially lay out the blueprint for how our brains and our bodies should develop as kind of, an initial template that then kind of interacts with our environment to create our outcomes, to create our life. Each of us has a very unique genetic profile, with obviously the exception of biological twins. And our genetic profile is marked by these things called mutations. So these are caused when our cells are splitting or dividing, and when we receive a mutation on one of our genes, this is what is often responsible for certain disorders and illnesses or a certain predisposition for conditions like depression.
另一个可以用来责怪你父母的理由，这个可能就很适合你。但我们的遗传基因是从我们的父亲和母亲那里继承来的。它们基本上为我们的大脑和身体如何发育勾勒出了蓝图，作为一种初始模板，然后与我们的环境相互作用，从而创造出我们的结果，创造出我们的人生。我们每个人都有非常独特的基因图谱，当然，同卵双胞胎除外。我们的基因图谱的标志是这些被称为突变的东西。这些是由我们的细胞分裂引起的，当我们某个基因上发生突变时，这往往就是某些疾病和不适，或者是对抑郁症等状况的特定易感性的原因。
So when scientists started using genetic mapping to figure out why some people develop certain conditions for seemingly no apparent reason and others don't, eventually they turned to depression to see what they could find in our DNA, what kind of secrets they could unlock. And here's what they found. So they believe that as many as 40% of those of us who have depression can trace a link back to something in our genetics,
所以当科学家开始使用基因图谱来弄清楚为什么有些人会在无缘无故的情况下患上某些疾病而其他人却没有时，他们最终转向了抑郁症，看看能在我们的DNA中发现什么，能够解开什么样的秘密。以下是他们的发现。他们认为，在我们这些患有抑郁症的人中，高达40%的人可以将病因追溯到我们基因中的某些东西，
which is most often identified by having a close family member or a relative who also has depression. But it's important here to note that doesn't necessarily mean that everyone with a mutation or family history is going to develop depression because often that gene needs to be activated by our environment and that accounts for the other 60% of our kind of risk factor or vulnerability. And this is where the interaction between family history and genetics can become a little bit tricky because a child who grows up with a parent or a person around them who has depression,
通常表现为家中有近亲或亲属也患有抑郁症。但这里需要注意的是，这并不意味着每个有基因突变或家族史的人都会患上抑郁症，因为通常这个基因需要由我们的环境来激活，而这占了我们另一半（约60%）的风险因素或易感性。这就是为什么家族史和遗传之间的相互作用会变得有点复杂，因为一个在患有抑郁症的父母或身边人陪伴下长大的孩子，
maybe they are more susceptible to the condition, not because of a genetic mutation or because they've inherited this gene, but because they've learned to mimic their parents' behavior. or they've experienced something, you know, perhaps uncomfortable in childhood that is related to their parents' experience. It's hard to separate whether the trigger, I guess, or the predisposing factor was genetics or our environment. And that's kind of a puzzle that we're yet to crack.
也许他们更容易患上这种疾病，不是因为基因突变或遗传了这个基因，而是因为他们学会了模仿父母的行为。或者他们在童年中经历了一些，你知道的，可能与父母的经历有关的不愉快的事情。我们很难区分诱因，或者说易感因素到底是基因还是我们的环境。这是一个我们尚未破解的谜题。
But when they dived further into what specific gene mutation was kind of responsible for upwards of 40% of cases, what they really found has truly changed how we approach. approach this condition. Our genes are responsible for how our brain processes and releases serotonin. And serotonin is the primary candidate for the reason we experience depressive symptoms. It's like the core neurotransmitter that we would hear about and that is discussed when we're talking about this condition. And there's been several studies that have shown this. You know, serotonin is definitely something you've heard about before. You probably mostly know it in terms of like the happy drug alongside dopamine, the happy chemical.
但当他们进一步深入研究究竟是哪种特定基因突变导致了高达40%的病例时，他们真正发现的东西彻底改变了我们对待这种疾病的方式。我们的基因决定了我们的大脑如何处理和释放血清素。血清素是我们产生抑郁症状的主要原因。它是我们在谈论这种疾病时听到和讨论的核心神经递质。已经有几项研究证明了这一点。你知道的，血清素绝对是你以前听说过的东西。你可能对它的了解主要局限于它是一种快乐药物，与多巴胺这种快乐化学物质齐名。
And that relationship between perhaps having a less formed serotonin system or less serotonin available in our brain and depression makes a lot of logical sense because this neurotransmitter is responsible for our mood, for our general levels of happiness and also things like sleep, which we know contribute. And because this mutation disrupts the release and how our brains process serotonin, people with depression may have less of this neurotransmitter available to them.
这种血清素系统发育不全或大脑中可用的血清素较少与抑郁症之间的关系在逻辑上讲得通，因为这种神经递质负责我们的情绪、整体幸福感以及睡眠等我们知道会有所影响的事情。由于这种基因突变会破坏血清素的释放以及我们大脑处理血清素的方式，抑郁症患者体内的这种神经递质可能会减少。
And that is what results in these symptoms that we typically associate with this condition. At the end of the day, I think what these findings really revealed is that this may be, you know, nothing more than just a chemical imbalance. and it's unfortunate but you know we can't go into our brain and turn on the serotonin tap whenever we'd like but we can take medications like selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors or basically what we
这就是导致我们通常与这种疾病相关联的这些症状的原因。归根结底，我认为这些发现真正揭示的是，这可能不过是一种化学失衡。很遗憾，但你知道的，我们无法随心所欲地进入大脑打开血清素的水龙头，但我们可以服用选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂等药物，或者基本上是我们
know as antidepressants and they work by preventing our neurons from sucking up all of that serotonin in our brain and keeping it in action for longer making more of it available to us that's obviously a really, really simple explanation, but the apparent effectiveness, the repeatedly shown effectiveness of this type of antidepressants really points to depression having a biological origin in how our brain releases and processes serotonin in particular. Hormonally as well studies conducted in 2011, actually a bunch of them, not just conducted during that year, across a number of years. They also suggest that major depression may involve an overactive hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis. Very long word, very long term, but
所知的抗抑郁药，它们的作用原理是阻止神经元吸收大脑中的所有血清素，使其保持更长时间的活性，从而让我们获得更多可用的血清素。这显然是一个非常非常简单的解释，但这类抗抑郁药显而易见的、被反复证明的有效性确实表明，抑郁症具有生物学根源，特别是在我们的大脑如何释放和处理血清素方面。荷尔蒙方面也是如此，2011年进行的研究（实际上是一堆研究，不仅限于那一年，而是跨越了好几年）也表明，重度抑郁症可能涉及下丘脑-垂体-肾上腺轴的过度活跃。这是一个很长的词，一个很长的术语，但
essentially it's responsible for a lot of our hormones, including estrogen, which, as you may have guessed it, also impacts serotonin levels. All of it comes back to this one little neurotransmitter. But we're going to talk on this a little bit more later, specifically the hormonal influences. I want to quickly return to that question. How long does this last? How long? How long is your depression going to last? You know, I can't answer that for you, but I think if it's the case that a lot of your condition is coming from hereditary factors like genetics, which consequently impact your innate biology, I think the unfortunate news is that, you know, sadly you cannot rewire your brain. So not accounting for the protective factors we're going to discuss later on.
本质上它负责我们的许多激素，包括雌激素，正如你可能猜到的那样，它也会影响血清素水平。这一切都归结于这一个小小的神经递质。但我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论，特别是激素的影响。我想迅速回到那个问题。这会持续多久？多久？你的抑郁症会持续多久？你知道的，我无法为你解答，但我想，如果你的很多病情来自于遗传因素（如基因），而这反过来又影响了你的先天生物学，那么不幸的消息是，悲哀的是，你无法重新连接你的大脑。所以还不算我们稍后要讨论的保护因素。
It's really hard to say it may be chronic, but it's not untreatable. SSRIs are highly reliable. They've been systematically tested for their effectiveness in these situations, particularly in response to this chemical imbalance explanation. But the fact that they don't work for everyone points to this kind of deeper truth that not everyone's depressive symptoms have a genetic or even a neural origin to do with some kind of serotonin dysfunction or hormonal dysfunction. Certain personality types and people of certain temperaments may also be more susceptible. And there's a few that we typically look at, particularly those who are rejection sensitive, self-critical, anxious worrying,
很难说它可能是慢性的，但并非不可治疗。SSRI（选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂）具有高度可靠性。人们已经针对它们在这些情况下的有效性进行了系统性测试，特别是针对这种化学失衡的解释。但它们并非对每个人都有效这一事实指向了一个更深层次的真相：并非每个人的抑郁症状都有基因或神经层面的根源，与某种血清素功能障碍或荷尔蒙功能障碍有关。某些人格类型和具有特定气质的人也可能更易感。我们通常会关注几种人，特别是那些对拒绝敏感、自我批判、焦虑担忧
or personally reserved. And then, of course, we have things like extraneous events and circumstances. It's not all about temperament and personality. The things that happen to us create the thought patterns and the response that our brain is going to have. So trauma, as we know, is a massive contributor. There is a large consensus that indicates that childhood trauma is significantly involved in the development of depression. In one study they conducted in 2015 that I found so comprehensive and incredibly well done,
或性格内向的人。当然，还有诸如外部事件和环境之类的事情。这并不完全取决于气质和性格。发生在我们身上的事情创造了我们大脑将要产生的思维模式和反应。因此，正如我们所知，创伤是一个巨大的诱发因素。有广泛的共识表明，童年创伤与抑郁症的发展显着相关。在他们2015年进行的一项研究中，我发现它非常全面且做得非常好，
researchers ask people to retrospectively recall childhood trauma, and they also measured their rates of chronic depression. and the relationship between these two things was really, really significant. Our environment, particularly our early childhood environment, is so powerful. And things like neglect and abuse have the capacity to literally change how our neural and global structure is developing, in some instances even shrinking or delaying development. Our brains are also not great at forgetting trauma. We have an evolutionary and a survival instinct to remember the bad things that happen to us. And even when, you know, they do come through as suppressed memories, the body does not forget.
研究人员要求人们回顾性地回忆童年创伤，他们还测量了他们慢性抑郁症的发病率，这两者之间的关系真的非常非常显著。我们的环境，尤其是我们早期的童年环境，是如此强大。忽视和虐待等事情具有改变我们的神经和全球结构发育方式字面含义的能力，在某些情况下甚至会收缩或延迟发育。我们的大脑也不太擅长忘记创伤。我们有一种进化和生存的本能，去记住发生在我们身上的坏事。甚至当，你知道的，它们作为被压抑的记忆浮现时，身体并没有忘记。
And that stress and that experience does, unfortunately, stay with us. These factors, though, they all have something in common, the ones that we've talked about. And I want to emphasize that commonality really clearly. None of these factors, none of these pre-defendants. disposing determinants are within our control. None of them. None of them could be our fault. There is nothing in that list that we have agency over. You know, our genetics, absolutely not. Our personality, some would argue maybe, but I would say not. The trauma and the things that we experience, our hormone levels. If we could, we would definitely make it so that we did not have
不幸的是，这种压力和经历确实留在了我们身边。不过，这些因素都有一个共同点，就是我们讨论过的那些。我想非常明确地强调这种共同性。这些因素中没有一个是我们可以控制的，没有一个易感决定因素在我们控制范围内。没有一个。没有一个可能是我们的错。在该列表中没有任何东西是我们拥有自主权的。你知道的，我们的基因，绝对没有。我们的性格，有人可能会争辩说也许有，但我会说没有。我们经历的创伤和事情，我们的激素水平。如果我们能做到，我们绝对会避免
this predisposition, that we did not have this experience. Once again, that's misconception number two. And something that we have to say is that you do not get to control how this condition manifests. And I think that really takes a lot of the shame away from it because it's not something that you have decided to opt into. It's not something that you want to be dealing with, you know, depending on your experience, I would say most of us would prefer not to be depressed the majority of the time. Okay, I think it's time for a quick break to gather our thoughts, grab a cup of tea, tell your friends that you love them. And when we return, I really want to discuss precipitating factors, protective factors, and also some of the new treatments that we are seeing for depression,
这种易感性，避免这种经历。再说一次，这是第二个误区。我们必须指出的一点是，你无法控制这种疾病如何表现。我认为这确实消除了很多耻辱感，因为它不是你决定选择加入的事情。这不是你想处理的事情，你知道的，根据你的经历，我想我们大多数人大部分时间都不希望自己抑郁。好吧，我想是时候休息一下，整理一下思绪，喝杯茶，告诉你的朋友你爱他们。当我们回来时，我非常想讨论诱发因素、保护因素，以及我们看到的针对抑郁症的一些新疗法，
including the use of psychedelics. Not as fun as it sounds, actually, but really interesting. And also why some people think that things like ketamine or even, nature may be particularly healing for people with these symptoms. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
包括迷幻药的使用。其实并不像听起来那么有趣，但非常有趣。还有为什么有些人认为氯胺酮甚至大自然等东西可能对有这些症状的人特别有治疗作用。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，探讨那些主导健康产业的不切实际的
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Percent。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过这一切的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。坦白说，1984年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备一整天都在聊霹雳可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Pie. or wherever you get your podcasts.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎来到我的新播客“艰难的方法”（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太卷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free.
绝对是。这是两种不同水平的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客“艰难的方法”中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费
iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“艰难的方法”并立即收听。2023年，前“钻石王老五”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。桑兹女士，你两次篡改了这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到
what their tax dollars. were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是“爱情陷阱”（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，
We've done a bit of an overview of what people typically see as the causes of depression, but what kind of triggers a depressive episode or something like persistent depressive disorder? This is where we turn our focus to precipitating factors. These are things that initiate or promote the onset of a condition. The main offender, I would say, is stressful or adverse life experiences. These two psychologists actually created a scale for what these might be, and which ones may be more predictive of depression. So it's called the stress scale. And number one is the death of, obviously, of a spouse or of your child, things like divorce and separation.
这一切还没有结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“爱情陷阱”播客。我们已经大致了解了人们通常认为的抑郁症病因，但究竟是什么引发了抑郁发作或持续性抑郁障碍之类的情况呢？这就是我们将焦点转向诱发因素的时候。这些是引发或促进病情发作的事情。我要说的主罪魁祸首是压力或逆境生活经历。这两位心理学家实际上创建了一个量表，用以衡量这些可能是什么，以及哪些可能更能预测抑郁症。所以它被称为压力量表。排在第一位的是配偶或孩子的死亡，以及离婚和分居等事情。
imprisonment, the death of a close family member injury, but then surprisingly, we actually see some things that are more positive. So things like marriage and retirement and the birth of a child can be so stressful even though we see them as beautiful that they trigger this kind of emotional and deeper reaction. Let's focus in on some of the events that particularly pertain to our 20s, in particular significant life changes, things like grief, but also moving out of home, our first significant breakup and deep feelings of things like isolation and alienation. There are so many other unique things. And when multiple of these events occur in a short period of time, this has what we would call a cumulative effect. So the prolonged accumulation of momentary stress leads to an increase
监禁、至亲的死亡、受伤，但令人惊讶的是，我们实际上看到了一些更积极的事情。因此，像结婚、退休和孩子出生这样的事情可能会带来很大的压力，尽管我们认为它们是美好的，但它们会引发这种情绪和更深层的反应。让我们把焦点放在一些特别与我们的20多岁相关的事件上，特别是重大的生活变故，诸如悲伤，还有搬出家门、我们的第一次重大分手以及诸如孤立感和疏离感等深层感受。还有许多其他独特的事情。当其中多个事件在短时间内发生时，就会产生我们称之为累积效应的后果。因此，短暂压力的长期积累会导致
in long-term cumulative stress and just general impacts on our overall health, perhaps because of the release of things like cortisol and adrenaline. It's a biological interaction that has the name post-adrenaline blues. When we go through something intensely shocking and life-altering, our bodies respond to this as they would respond to danger or a threat. And they pump us with a nice cocktail of noropenephrine, it's also known as adrenaline, and cortisol, which is the main stress hormone that's released from our thyroid. When that danger passes, when that event kind of fades, when the wedding is over,
长期累积压力的增加，并对我们的整体健康产生一般性影响，这可能是由于皮质醇和肾上腺素等物质的释放造成的。这是一种被称为“肾上腺素衰退综合征”（post-adrenaline blues）的生物学相互作用。当我们经历极度震惊和改变生活的事情时，我们的身体对此的反应就像应对危险或威胁一样。它们为我们注入了一剂美好的去甲肾上腺素（也称为肾上腺素）和皮质醇（甲状腺释放的主要压力荷尔蒙）的鸡尾酒。当危险过去，当事件逐渐消退，当婚礼结束时，
when you've unpacked all your boxes in the new city, you crash. And your body is trying to restore things to normal. And what that can induce is a depressive period or a depressive episode. So yes, one event may be enough to really trigger something like situational depression. or an adjustment disorder with depressive symptoms, but it can also interact with some of our earlier predispositions and create other elements or symptoms or even a depressive episode because it is so shocking, because it has really caused us to perhaps rethink life,
当你把新城市的所有箱子都拆开后，你崩溃了。你的身体正在努力将一切恢复正常。这可能会诱发抑郁期或抑郁发作。所以，是的，单一事件可能就足以真正引发诸如情境性抑郁症之类的状况，或者伴有抑郁症状的适应障碍，但它也可能与我们早期的某些易感性相互作用，并产生其他元素、症状甚至是抑郁发作，因为它是如此令人震惊，因为它确实导致我们重新思考生活，
it's made or limited our, you know, the availability of our coping mechanisms. It's really transformed how we see the world and is naturally, incredibly strong. But something that's kind of missing from this discussion, I think, and is often missing and rarely spoken about, is protective factors. We like to focus on the negatives. Maybe that in itself is symptomatic, but also our society is rather pessimistic. I think our obsession with predisposition kind of also links to that innate stigma.
它限制了我们应对机制的可用性。它真正改变了我们看待世界的方式，并且自然而然地具有极其强大的力量。但这场讨论中似乎缺少了某种东西，我认为这种东西经常缺失且很少被谈论，那就是保护因素。我们喜欢关注消极面。也许这本身就是一种症状，但也可能是因为我们的社会相当悲观。我认为我们对易感性的痴迷也与这种天生的污名化有关。
If we know how depression is created or developed, maybe we can eliminate it from society, which I personally don't think. is quite valuable. Maybe that's a controversial thing to say, but for me, you know, yeah, you have your bad days, but if someone kind of gave me a magical button, I think I'd have some doubts. I don't want to say there's been benefits, but there's been definite perspective shifts and various outlooks that my depression has kind of given me. You know, who could be, who could say I would be even making this podcast now if I didn't have this experience and didn't, you know, relate to some of the deeper discussions happening around mental health and psychology, but I also understand that part of that comes from the attitude I have towards
如果我们知道抑郁症是如何产生或发展的，也许我们可以将其从社会中消除，但我个人认为这并没有太大的价值。也许这是一个有争议的说法，但对我来说，是的，你会有糟糕的日子，但如果有人给我一个魔法按钮，我想我会有些疑虑。我不想说这带来了什么好处，但我的抑郁症确实带给我明确的视角转变和各种观点。谁能说，如果没有这段经历，没有与围绕心理健康和心理学展开的更深层讨论产生共鸣，我现在还能制作这个播客呢？但我也明白，部分原因来自于我对
when I'm experiencing. And attitude, as silly as it sounds, it's not going to cure your depression, but there has been evidence that it does minimize your distress and perhaps the severity of your symptom profile because of its role as a protective factor. Things like, you know, if you're innately pessimistic versus optimistic, which we'll talk about in a second, that is going to influence your thinking style and also your coping mechanisms. But let's discuss a few other of these protective factors that are really impactful when we talk about depression. Like I mentioned, personal attributes, but then things like social support networks, a sense of community. Really nobody can overstate the beauty and the importance of belonging. It kind of coats us in a
正在经历的事情所持的态度。态度听起来很傻，它治愈不了你的抑郁症，但有证据表明，由于它作为保护因素发挥了作用，它确实能最大限度地减少你的痛苦以及可能出现的症状严重程度。诸如你天生悲观还是乐观（我们稍后会讨论这一点），这会影响你的思维方式以及你的应对机制。但让我们讨论其他几个在谈论抑郁症时极具影响力的保护因素。正如我所提到的，个人属性，还有社交支持网络、社区归属感。真的没有人能高估归属感的美好和重要性。它为我们穿上了一层
bit of a protective shield. Also a strong sense of identity, a sense of self, even things like spirituality or your connection with a particular religion, that really encompasses a reason for being. And then also things like depression, physical health and fitness. I think it's valuable that we focus on that last one because I know the opinions around it are very nuanced and at times contradictory. From an evidence-based perspective, there is, there are a lot of findings that exercise as a behavioral intervention does alleviate some of the symptoms of depression. In a few large studies, one in particular, which was conducted here in Australia, actually published this year, 2023, they found that active men and women became depressed at much lower rates than
保护盾。此外，强烈的认同感、自我意识，甚至诸如灵性或你与特定宗教的联系之类的东西，都真正包含了一个人存在的理由。还有抑郁症、身体健康和体能。我认为关注最后一点很有价值，因为我知道围绕它的观点非常细致，有时甚至是矛盾的。从循证的角度来看，有许多研究发现，作为一种行为干预，锻炼确实可以缓解抑郁症状。在几项大型研究中，有一项特别是在澳大利亚这里进行的、于今年（2023年）发表的研究发现，活跃的男性和女性患抑郁症的比率远低于
sedentary people, even if they exercise for only a few minutes a day or a few days a week. but the kind of precise mechanisms by which bodily movements alter brain functions to improve our mood really remains unclear as do the differences in people's responses. So in every study, the researchers looked at some people's depression was alleviated, while others remained unchanged. I also think we need to be skeptical when we're promoting things like exercise because A, like we showed, it doesn't work for everyone. B, I think when we read these findings without considering the broader context and interactions between exercise and other factors, we can sometimes reduce these conclusions to suggest that,
久坐不动的人，即使他们每天只锻炼几分钟或一周锻炼几天。但是身体运动改变大脑功能以改善我们的情绪的确切机制仍不清楚，人们对它的反应差异也是如此。因此，在每一项研究中，研究人员都发现有些人的抑郁得到了缓解，而另一些人则没有变化。我也认为，当我们在推广诸如锻炼之类的事情时，我们需要保持怀疑态度，因为 A，正如我们所展示的那样，它并不对每个人都有效。B，我认为，当我们在不考虑更广泛背景以及锻炼与其他因素之间相互作用的情况下阅读这些发现时，有时会将这些结论简化为暗示
you know, just buying a pair of running shoes and going for a jog is the magical answer. And C, I think it shouldn't be considered the first sign of treatment for some people. I think in many ways that would be unethical. Also, when we think about the impact oppression has on our motivation, it's really hard for your therapists to be like, oh, just go for a run when you can't even get out of bed. Or it also excludes people with certain disabilities. It's a protective factor. I will say it's not a cure. And to sell it as anything more than that, I think would be very misleading. You know, look at elite athletes as an example. We've seen so many people like Simone Biles and Naomi Osaka come out and talk really
你知道，只要买一双跑鞋去慢跑就是神奇的答案。C，我认为对某些人来说，它不应被视为首选的治疗迹象。我认为在许多方面这都是不道德的。此外，当我们想到抑郁对我们动力的影响时，当患者甚至无法下床时，治疗师很难说“哦，去跑跑步吧”。或者这也排除了某些残疾人士。这是一个保护因素。我要说的是它不是灵丹妙药。如果把它吹嘘成超越这一范畴的东西，我认为是非常误导人的。看一看精英运动员的例子。我们已经看到像西蒙娜·拜尔斯（Simone Biles）和大阪直美这样的人公开谈论
openly about their mental health problems. And I'm going to bet some pretty good money that these people are exercising for more than 45 minutes a day. So the relationship that has been promised between physical activity and an alleviation of mental distress isn't quite there. What it seems to be is a combination. If we have a strong support network, particularly of people we can speak openly with, that really lessens the load, as does, like we said, a sense of being a purpose and personality or temperament. The main one being, like we said, the distinction between being an optimist or a pessimist. You know, do you see the world and your future is generally positive? Or are you expecting the worst case scenario? Also, I think depression can make us feel like we're all
他们的心理健康问题。我敢打包票，这些人每天锻炼的时间肯定超过45分钟。因此，人们所承诺的体育活动与缓解心理困扰之间的关系并没有真正体现出来。它似乎是一个组合。如果我们有一个强大的支持网络，特别是那些我们可以畅所欲言的人，这确实能减轻负担，就像我们所说的那样，有目标感以及个性和气质。最主要的一点，正如我们所说，是乐观主义者还是悲观主义者之间的区别。你知道，你看到的世界和你的未来总体上是积极的吗？还是你在期待最坏的情况？另外，我认为抑郁症会让我们觉得自己都是
pessimists. The outlook carried through, though, by our prior predisposition for optimism, even just, even just the slight sense, even just that like very hidden voice in our head that says, all right, let's keep focusing, things are going to turn out all right, that can maybe counteract that negative thought pattern that we associate with these symptoms. Something I've also found really effective is active coping skills, forcing myself to journal what I was feeling, especially as a way to look back and see how far I progressed, but also as a reminder to myself during future hard times that this is not the first time I've been through this. I've survived. I've pulled through. There are beautiful things waiting for me. That is a really
悲观主义者。然而，我们此前对乐观主义的倾向所承载的远景，即使只是、即使只是那种微弱的感觉，即使只是我们脑海中那个非常隐藏的声音在说：“好吧，让我们继续专注，事情会好起来的”，也可能可以抵消我们与这些症状联系在一起的消极思维模式。我也发现非常有效的一点是积极的应对技巧，强迫自己将感受写在日记里，尤其是以此作为回顾并看到自己取得多大进步的方式，同时也是在未来的艰难时期提醒自己，这不是我第一次经历这一切。我挺过来了。我坚持过来了。有美好的事物在等着我。这是我管理自己正在经历的事情的方法中非常
important and valuable part of my approach to managing what I'm going through, having a perspective. Okay, so the final thing that we've been missing from this conversation has been discussions of treatment. If we're taking a biomedical approach to depression, that perspective tells us, that like any other form of illness, depression should be managed through a series of treatments or interventions. I also want to state that this should not be taken as advised, like I said before. I'm not in the position to give you actual medical recommendation or prescriptions because I guess I don't know you personally, but knowledge is power and I think psychoeducation is power. So consider this just an introductory overview or glance at what is actually out there.
重要且有价值的一部分，拥有一个视角。好吧，我们在这场讨论中一直遗漏的最后一部分是对治疗的讨论。如果我们对抑郁症采取生物医学方法，这种观点告诉我们，像任何其他形式的疾病一样，抑郁症应该通过一系列治疗或干预措施来管理。我还想声明，这不应被视为建议，就像我之前所说的那样。我没有立场给你实际的医疗建议或处方，因为我不了解你个人，但知识就是力量，我认为心理教育就是力量。所以请把这仅仅当作一个介绍性的概述，或者对实际情况的一瞥。
So there are two main forms of treatment that we typically see. That's medication and therapy. We already know the basics behind why antidepressants work. Depression involves changes in brain chemistry and that can change how people respond to the world. And so these kinds of medication can correct the imbalance of chemicals in the brain such as that a natural balance is restored. I have an old episode on this called antidepressants, literally just antidepressants, and it basically explains my own experience on Lexapro, which I've been on since I was around 20, and it felt like the right option for me.
所以我们通常看到的治疗主要有两种形式，即药物治疗和心理治疗。我们已经知道抗抑郁药为何起作用的基础知识。抑郁症涉及大脑化学物质的变化，这会改变人们对世界的反应。因此，这类药物可以纠正大脑中化学物质的失衡，从而恢复自然平衡。我有一集关于这个的老节目，叫“抗抑郁药”，字面意思就是抗抑郁药，它基本上解释了我自己服用来士普（Lexapro）的经历，我从20岁左右开始服用，这感觉对我来说是正确的选择。
I would, you know, had been going to therapy for a while. I made the lifestyle changes, and I think I got to the realization that what I was dealing with wasn't going to be fixed through my behavior. And it really personally did change my life. and four years on, it's, you know, it's second nature to be taking this medication. The times I have tried to go off it have been fucking horrendous, like dizziness, irritation, nausea, and, you know, sometimes I do worry that I will be dependent my whole life, but I think I'm honestly a little bit scared of who I'll be without it.
我当时已经，你知道的，去接受了一段时间的心理治疗。我做出了生活方式的改变，我想我意识到我所处理的事情是无法通过我的行为来解决的。它真的改变了我个人的生活。四年过去了，你知道的，服用这种药物已经成了第二天性。我曾尝试停药的几次经历简直糟糕透顶，比如头晕、易怒、恶心，而且，你知道的，有时我确实担心自己一辈子都会依赖它，但我认为老实说我有点害怕没有它我会变成什么样。
And, you know, when the time is right, I'll try it again and I'll see what happens, but it's definitely something to be discussed before you go on it. It's not something that you go on to temperate. temporarily relieve your hopelessness or your sadness, it's like a two-year thing kind of minimum. And it's widely believed that these medical interventions, they work best when combined with some kind of talking therapy, one that really gets to the core of how you're processing your reality and the nature of your thoughts. Like we always say on the show, a problem spoken out loud is half the problem. So the two.
而且，你知道的，当时机成熟时，我会再次尝试，看看会发生什么，但这绝对是在你服用之前需要讨论的事情。这不是你为了暂时缓解绝望或悲伤而服用的东西，这大概是一个至少持续两年的过程。人们普遍认为，当这些医疗干预措施与某种谈话疗法相结合时，效果最好，这种疗法真正触及你如何处理现实以及思想本质的核心。就像我们在节目中常说的那样，说出口的问题就等于解决了问题的一半。所以这两种
types that are most prominent, I would say, are cognitive behavioral therapy, CBT, if you've heard of that before, and interpersonal therapy. So we're going to start with cognitive behavioral therapy. It is perhaps the most widely practiced and effective form of psychotherapy, and it operates on the principle that our thoughts, our beliefs, our feelings, and therefore our behaviors are interconnected. And by identifying and challenging negative or distorted thought patterns, we bring about positive changes and our emotions and our actions. Interpersonal therapy is a bit different and it's a time-limited form of psychotherapy. Once again, psychotherapy is also known as kind of talking therapy and it centers on improving our personal relationships and addressing the emotional issues within that context that may be
最突出的类型，我要说的是，认知行为疗法（如果你以前听说过的话，简称 CBT）和人际关系疗法。所以我们将从认知行为疗法开始。它也许是实践最广泛、最有效的心理治疗形式，其运作原则是我们的想法、信念、感觉以及因此产生的行为是相互关联的。通过识别和挑战消极或扭曲的思维模式，我们可以对我们的情绪和行动带来积极的改变。人际关系疗法则略有不同，它是一种限时的心理治疗形式。再次说明，心理治疗也被称为谈话疗法，它以改善我们的人际关系为中心，并解决可能正在
contributing to how we're feeling. I think by exploring our past or current relationships even, by exploring our attachment style, our communication, life transitions as well, we can really gain these insights into how these discrete aspects of our lives are actually influencing our deeper emotional well-being. But I want to talk about some of the more experimental incoming treatments as well because treatment for depression, specifically major depressive disorder, has stayed relatively the same for the last two decades, but we are seeing a lot of new presentations and rising rates. And that's made a lot of scientists and researchers really question whether we could be doing better. You know, back in the day, Freud used to
导致我们情绪状况的语境中的情感问题。我认为，通过探索我们的过去甚至是当前的人际关系，通过探索我们的依恋风格、沟通方式以及生活转变，我们真的可以深入了解这些生活中的离散方面是如何实际影响我们更深层的情感健康的。但我还想谈谈一些更具实验性的新型疗法，因为针对抑郁症（特别是重度抑郁症）的治疗在过去二十年中相对保持不变，但我们看到了很多新的表现形式和上升的发病率。这让许多科学家和研究人员真正质疑我们是否可以做得更好。你知道的，过去，弗洛伊德曾经
treat his patients with cocaine. And it seems like we're coming back full circle with the introduction of what we would typically see as illicit substances like ketamine or LSD now being used in a clinical medical setting. So you've probably heard about this, but I want to clear it up. No doctor is going to hand you over a bag of whatever drug and say go nuts. They're not going to ask you to go and source it for yourself. It is highly regulated, highly protected. In 2019, the US actually approved ketamine-based. nasal spray for the first time, but it's very much used for specific cases. You know, when we're dealing with addictive drugs, that have been proven to be very destructive and now we're trying
用可卡因治疗他的病人。随着通常被视为非法物质的氯胺酮或LSD现在被用于临床医疗环境，我们似乎又回到了原点。所以你可能听说过这个，但我想澄清一下。没有医生会递给你一袋什么毒品然后说随便用。他们不会要求你自己去寻找它。它是高度监管、受到高度保护的。2019年，美国实际上首次批准了基于氯胺酮的鼻喷雾剂，但它很大程度上用于特定病例。你知道的，当我们处理已被证明具有极大致命性、而我们现在正试图
to leverage them for something productive. You've really got to be cautious, you know, especially around their, you know, the propensity or the risk for substance abuse. I want to explain why it may work, though. With most medications like Valium or even, you know, the problem, you know, Lexapro or an SSRI, the antidepressive or anti-anxiety effect is only going to last when that drug is in your system. When the Valium goes away, when the SSRI goes away, you're going to get rebound anxiety or some kind of withdrawal. But when you take ketamine, it actually triggers reactions in your cortex that enable brain connections to regrow. It's the reaction to ketamine, not the presence of ketamine in the body that constitutes its effect.
利用它们来实现某些建设性目的的成瘾药物时。你真的必须保持谨慎，尤其是考虑到它们对药物滥有的倾向或风险。不过我想解释一下它为什么起作用。对于大多数药物（如安定，甚至，你知道的，来士普或SSRI），抗抑郁或抗焦虑效果只会在该药物在你的体内时持续。当安定消失时，当SSRI消失时，你会出现反跳性焦虑或某种戒断症状。但当你服用氯胺酮时，它实际上会引发皮层中的反应，从而使大脑连接重新生长。是氯胺酮引发的反应，而不是氯胺酮在体内的存在构成了它的效果。
Most of the research has been coming out of Yale, and the responses and the findings have been genuinely mind-blowing, especially when we think about how stagnant some of the research on depression has been for quite some time. They've done a number of studies, as has John Hopkins as well, and in one in particular, more than half of the participants who were administered, this nasal ketamine spray, showed a significant decrease in depressive symptoms after just 24 hours. These are patients who felt no meaningful improvement on other antidepressant medications or through other forms of therapy.
大部分研究都来自耶鲁大学，其反应和发现在很大程度上确实令人震惊，特别是当我们考虑到抑郁症研究在相当长一段时间内停滞不前时。他们进行了多项研究，约翰霍普金斯大学也是如此，其中一项研究显示，超过一半使用这种氯胺酮鼻喷雾剂的参与者在短短24小时后，抑郁症状就有了显著减轻。这些患者在使用其他抗抑郁药物或其他形式的治疗时，并未感受到任何有意义的改善。
And I think that's just so life-changing. I can't even imagine how profound that would be. Then we also have psychedelics, particularly psilocybin. So that's more commonly known as, you know, magic mushrooms essentially. it's psilocybin is the active ingredient in this recreational drug. And it's a hallucinogen. It changes the brain's response to a chemical in our brain, which you may have already guessed it. It's serotonin.
我认为这简直太改变人生了。我甚至无法想象那是多么深远的意义。然后我们还有迷幻药，特别是赛洛西宾（psilocybin）。这更通常被称为，你知道的，神奇蘑菇。赛洛西宾是这种娱乐性药物中的活性成分。它是一种致幻剂。它会改变大脑对大脑中某种化学物质的反应，你可能已经猜到了。那就是血清素。
And when broken down, when psilocybin is broken down, it causes an altered state of consciousness and perception. And what this does is cause our brains to use different neural pathways as it processes this substance. essentially opening us up to experiences, connecting us to our surroundings and triggering an alerted or mild, you know, mild to severe hallucinogenic state. When we experience chronic depression, this can often reduce neuroplasticity and it causes us to feel very stuck. That's where that hopelessness and that sadness comes from. But psychedelics do the opposite. They really encourage the growth of new connections through this hallucinogenic effect of expanding the way our neurons fire. Now, once again, a very clear disclaimer here. This is not stuff that you would buy on, I don't know,
当被分解时，当赛洛西宾被分解时，它会导致意识和知觉状态的改变。这使得我们的大脑在处理这种物质时使用不同的神经通路，本质上向我们的经历敞开心扉，将我们与周围环境连接起来，并触发一种轻度或从轻度到重度的致幻状态。当我们经历慢性抑郁症时，这通常会降低神经可塑性，并导致我们感到非常卡住。这就是绝望和悲伤的来源。但迷幻药则相反。它们通过这种通过扩大神经放电方式的致幻效应，真正鼓励新连接的生长。现在，再次说明，这是一个非常明确的免责声明。这些不是你在，我不知道，
the dark web. This is medication that is being severely and cautiously vetted and administered in a clinical setting. And in one study, a single dose of a synthetic version of this component of magic mushrooms, it improved depression in people with what we would call a treatment-resistant form of the condition. And importantly, what's really valuable when we are studying new treatments, particularly new medical interventions, is whether the study was double-blind. So meaning neither the participants or the researchers knew which one of the trial patients was actually receiving the drug. So this helps eliminate things like placebo effects. which we know can be quite common.
暗网上买的东西。这是在临床环境中受到严格和谨慎审查并给药的药物。在一项研究中，单剂量的这种神奇蘑菇成分的合成版本改善了患有我们所谓的该病难治性形式的人的抑郁症。重要的是，当我们研究新疗法（特别是新的医疗干预措施）时，非常有价值的一点是该研究是否是双盲的。这意味着参与者和研究人员都不知道哪个试验患者实际在接受药物。这有助于消除我们已知可能相当普遍的安慰剂效应。
And I think the other interest in psychedelics is that psilocybin or even LSD, according to some statements, some opinions, it doesn't really have the abuse potential in the same fashion as things like cocaine or opioids or alcohol or nicotine. However, there is still so much that we don't know. So I think for now it's best to stick to the approved therapies. that are recommended by a licensed professional, a talking therapy, an antidepressant. I think that it's such fascinating research. I think that people who use these drugs recreationally before they started undergoing scientific testing have regularly, regularly said that this is an impact and an influence that they personally experience outside of a medical setting.
而且我认为人们对迷幻剂的另一个兴趣在于，根据一些说法和观点，裸盖菇素甚至LSD，并不像可卡因、阿片类药物、酒精或尼古丁那样具有同等程度的滥用潜力。然而，我们仍然有太多未知。所以我想目前最好还是坚持由执照专业人士推荐的批准疗法，比如谈话疗法、抗抑郁药。我认为这是一项非常迷人的研究。我认为，在这些药物开始接受科学测试之前，那些将其用于娱乐的人们就经常、一再地表示，这是他们在医疗环境之外亲身经历的一种冲击和影响。
So I'm very excited to see where that goes. You know, I can't speak to this personally. but what I do kind of want to finish on is kind of where I'm at now. Given we've had this broader overview, I think I want to take some time to reflect on, you know, where that knowledge kind of leaves us. If you're someone who is experiencing depression, what can you really take from that? But what can you really take from my experience?
所以我很高兴看到这个领域的发展。你知道，我无法亲自谈论这一点，但我想总结的是我目前的状况。鉴于我们已经有了这个更广泛的概述，我想花点时间反思一下这些知识给我们留下了什么。如果你是一个正在经历抑郁症的人，你究竟能从中得到什么？但你究竟能从我的经历中得到什么？
I think I'm at this point. I've said this before where I'm really seeking to manage and not to cure. It's kind of this really stoic perspective where I'm like, you know what, this is my reality. and, you know, sadly, there is not some switch that's going to change how my brain operates. I've just got to accept it. Also, you know, a final misconception that I really wanted to bunk is that it's not as if my life is devoid of happiness. You know, I have really happy moments.
我想我已经到了这个阶段。我以前说过，我真正追求的是控制而不是治愈。这是一种非常斯多葛派的视角，我想，你知道吗，这就是我的现实，而且遗憾的是，并没有什么开关可以改变我大脑的运作方式。我只能接受它。还有，你知道，我想打破的一个最终误解是，这并不是说我的生活毫无快乐可言。你知道，我也有非常快乐的时刻。
I have an amazing family, incredible friends. I'm super grateful. And I do get to experience a lot of joy very readily, very rapidly. Depression is not just the absence of any feeling but sadness. It's not just sadness. It's more complicated than that. And I don't want people to think that that's all there is to a person. And then it will come to define them.
我有一个了不起的家庭，有不可思议的朋友。我超级感激。而且我确实能非常轻易、非常迅速地体验到很多快乐。抑郁症不仅仅是除了悲伤之外没有任何感觉。它不仅仅是悲伤。它比这更复杂。我不希望人们认为这就是一个人的一切，然后这会定义他们。
You know, I'm a good friend. I have hobbies and passions I love. I'm productive and I do things with a lot of love. I still feel incredibly deeply and I have dreams and goals. It's just that sometimes those things seem less clear to me. It doesn't mean that they're not there. I still think we face a lot of stigma, but it's so surprising that when you start having these conversations,
你知道，我是个好朋友，我有热爱的爱好和激情。我很有效率，我做的事情都充满了爱。我依然能感受到极其深刻的情感，我有梦想和目标。只是有时候这些事情在我看来不那么清晰了。这并不意味着它们不存在。我依然认为我们面临着很多污名，但令人惊讶的是，当你开始进行这些对话时，
you'll realize that every single one of us knows someone in some capacity who is experiencing something very, very similar. And that sense of not community, but that sense of not going at it alone, really is quite powerful for me. Depression can make you feel quite selfishly like you're the only person in the world, like you're the only person who is the same. sad and this miserable. And although you don't want other people in the boat with you,
你会意识到我们当中的每一个人，都在某种程度上认识某个正在经历非常、非常相似事情的人。这种感觉——不是社群感，而是那种不独自前行的感觉——对我来说确实相当强大。抑郁症会让你自私地觉得自己是世界上唯一的一个人，觉得只有你一个人这么悲伤、这么痛苦。虽然你不想让其他人上你的船，
you don't want to acknowledge that maybe they're going through the same thing, you know, you can't change that. And sometimes having an open, you know, open line of communication and open discussions about this are so valuable. So I really want to thank you for listening to today's episode. It was definitely a vulnerable one, I know. So if you're still with us, I hope that you're feeling very knowledgeable and you're feeling very optimistic. And if you're here for someone you know and someone you love. I promise it's not as hard as you think to take care of those who you care about. I know it can feel like you might say the wrong thing or do the wrong thing, but as long as you're showing up and you're asking how you can help, you're sending the
你不想承认他们可能也在经历同样的事情，你知道，你无法改变这一点。有时，保持开放的沟通渠道、对这些事情进行公开讨论是非常有价值的.所以我真的要感谢你收听今天的节目。我知道这绝对是一个敞开心扉的节目。所以如果你还在听，我希望你感到自己学到了很多，并且感到非常乐观。如果你是为了你认识和爱的人而来，我向你保证，照顾你关心的人并不像你想象的那么难。我知道你可能会觉得自已说错话或做错话，但只要你出现并询问如何提供帮助，偶尔发条信息看看他们过得怎么样，是否需要聊天，
occasional message just seeing how they're doing if they need to talk. You're really doing a lot more than most. You're doing the right thing. I promise that even listening to this is one step in the right direction. It's still such an unknown, I don't want to say disease, such an unknown condition. Despite all of that historical knowledge that we realistically should have, there is so much about it that is not understood, not just from a scientific perspective, but from a general societal perspective, but I hope that we're taking steps in the right direction. And I'm going to list some really fascinating studies that we talked about in this episode in the description, as well as some resources for when you can get further help, further information. You know,
你实际上做的事比大多数人都要多。你做的是对的。我向你保证，仅仅听这个节目就是朝着正确方向迈出的第一步。这仍然是一个未知的，我不想说疾病，这是一个未知的状况。尽管我们实际上应该具备所有这些历史知识，但关于它的许多事情仍然没有被理解，不仅从科学的角度来看是这样，从普遍的社会角度来看也是如此，但我希望我们正在朝着正确的方向迈出步伐。我将在描述中列出我们在本期节目中讨论的一些非常迷人的研究，以及一些可以让你获得进一步帮助、进一步信息的资源。你知道，
it's a tough time in our 20s and it's a bit tougher when you've got this kind of, like we say, black cloud over our heads, but I promise there's someone who's gone through it as well. There is so many good things coming and hard times as well, but you'll be able to approach them a lot better, a lot better. So I want to thank you for listening. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. And maybe your friend needs to hear this. Feel free to share it with them. I would really appreciate that as well. If you have an episode suggestion or you want to get in touch, if you like this episode or have some feedback, please follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram.
在我们二十几岁的时候这是一段艰难的时光，而当你头上像我们所说的那样顶着这片乌云时，日子就更艰难了，但我保证一定有人也经历过这一切。未来会有很多美好的事物，当然也会有困难的时期，但你能够更好地应对它们，好得多。所以我要感谢你的收听。如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。也许你的朋友需要听听这个。请随时与他们分享。我也会非常感激。如果你有节目建议或想取得联系，如果你喜欢这期节目或有一些反馈，请在Instagram上关注我@That Psychology Podcast。
I love receiving messages from you and seeing the community grow. So I want to thank you, listening to this episode, I hope you learned something. I'm glad you're here, and we will be back next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
我喜欢收到你们的信息，看到这个社群的成长。所以我要感谢你收听这一期节目，希望你学到了一些东西。很高兴你在这里，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Keer Games主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“艾伦女士，你把这份特定的测试篡改了两次，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客
you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app,
你获取播客的地方。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建设恢复力的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》，即TWO percent，在iHeartRadio应用程序上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。